A vote by the British people to leave the EU would be a huge and historic shock.
Here's what to expect in the aftermath.
The unprecedented occasion of a nation...
...leaving the biggest union of countries in history...
...may result in an emergency meeting of EU top brass.
Expect pro-Europe France and Germany to do everything...
...to show the alliance remains united.
While all this is happening, there could be wild swings in the British currency,...
...lively market reactions and even a crash.
One thing we know for sure is that just four days after the result,...
...all 28 EU leaders will hold a summit.
They'll be fearful inaction could give momentum to populist groups...
...looking to gain power following the UK's exit.
A general election is due to take place in Spain almost immediately.
European leaders will have to look strong...
...to prevent anti-EU feeling from other countries.
Into the first hundred days, could there be a domino effect of discontent?
Holland, Germany and France all have national elections coming up.
This could impact how they negotiate with the UK and could weaken Britain's hand.
In the long term, Britain has two whole years to negotiate an exit.
Some talks could take much longer, and the UK would lose some influence.
We can expect a chaotic and drawn-out drama...
...before we really know what the new Britain will look like.